[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de la disputa por el sahara
occidental- que ha tenido por décadas
marruecos y el movimiento
independentista frente polisario que
llama desde hace 45 años a ese
territorio como la república árabe
saharaui democrática un territorio
reconocido por más de 80 países y
miembros de la unión africana una zona
principalmente de arena pero con amplias
reservas de petróleo y reclamado desde
la década del 70 por marruecos para
hablar de este tema y entender el porqué
de este conflicto nos acompaña a
jerónimo delgado phd en relaciones
internacionales en la universidad de
ciudad del cabo investigador en el
centro de estudios africanos de la
universidad externado de bogotá en
colombia y presidente de la asociación
latinoamericana de estudios de asia y
áfrica gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 el sahara
occidental- ha sido un territorio
disputado por marruecos y por el
movimiento independentista del propio
territorio llamado frente polisario como
ya bien lo dijimos que es justamente que
le da el nombre actual desde 1976 hace
45 años sin embargo
tensiones bélicas no amparados que pide
saharaui y que sigue reclamando
marruecos
a ver lo que tenemos en este momento es
la pretensión del sáhara occidental' del
reconocimiento de su independencia desde
y un marruecos que invadió el territorio
que lo administrado desde entonces y que
se ha opuesto a no solamente a reconocer
la independencia del sahara occidental
sino que se ha opuesto a la realización
del referéndum de las naciones unidades
organizado por la minurso la misión de
naciones unidas para el sahara
occidental y que nos tiene en este
momento en una situación bastante
complicada
en la medida en que hace un par de meses
se reanudaron las hostilidades entre los
dos y no se ve en un futuro próximo la
posibilidad de realización del
referéndum porque incluso lo que tenemos
desde marruecos es una modificación del
censo electoral que haría que los
resultados del referéndum que se llevará
a cabo en este momento pues no fueran
acordes con los deseos de la población
saharaui
ahora quienes reconocen a este
territorio como la república árabe
saharaui democrática y quienes reconocen
la soberanía de marruecos en el sáhara
occidental además
bien hay más de 80 países que reconocen
la soberanía de la república árabe
saharaui democrática la mayoría de ellos
en asia áfrica y américa latina
sin embargo ningún país del mundo
reconoce bueno con excepción de donald
trump hace un par de meses en ningún
otro país del mundo reconoce la
soberanía de marruecos sobre el sahara
occidental esto hace parte pues responde
más bien a que sarah occidental hace
parte de los territorios no autónomos de
naciones unidas y la gran mayoría de
países han estado de acuerdo en que la
solución es la realización del
referéndum y hay unos elementos
adicionales si es que por ejemplo la
unión europea y eeuu en sus acuerdos
comerciales con marruecos han sacado el
territorio de sahara occidental- de
estos acuerdos en una en un
reconocimiento tácito de que si bien no
no hay reconocimiento de la soberanía si
hay un reconocimiento tácito de que esta
zona no pertenece a marruecos entonces
en este momento tenemos cerca de 80
países que reconocen al sahara el sahara
occidental es miembro de la unión
africana y la unión africana lo reconoce
como estado también ahora jerónimo cómo
viven los saharauis en medio de estas
constantes tensiones
bien hay dos o tres lugares donde viven
los saharauis en este momento los
primeros de ellos son los árabes que
viven en los territorios ocupados del
sáhara occidental es decir los
territorios bajo administración de
marruecos en ciudades como dajla en
ciudades como el aiún que viven bajo
ocupación
el segundo grupo poblacional son los
saharauis que viven en las zonas
liberadas del sáhara occidental' son
principalmente nómadas y el tercer grupo
de saharauis son los que viven en los
campamentos de refugiados cerca de la
ciudad de tindúf en el sur de argelia
son cuatro campamentos de refugiados más
uno adicional donde está el gobierno en
el exilio del sahara occidental
y son
grupos que viven en la mitad del
desierto en unas condiciones muy
difíciles con un acceso al agua bastante
complicado y en unos campamentos de
refugiados que se habían pensado
temporales pero que ya llevan más de
cuatro décadas y que se han convertido
de hecho los vemos en la imagen anterior
se han convertido casi que en
asentamientos permanentes de los
saharauis anónimos gracias por ayudarnos
a entender un poco sobre este conflicto
y cómo vive esta población gracias por
su tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 era jerónimo delgado ph en
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad de ciudad del cabo
investigadores centro de estudios
africanos y la universidad externado en
colombia ustedes también gracias por
siempre acompañarnos en este segmento de
france 24 continue con nosotros para más
actualización de noticias
internacionales
[Música]